have you thought about switching your
career moving to another city or making
another big change in your life maybe
you're thinking about it right now well
CBS News business analyst Joe
Schlessinger has a new book that gives
Financial advice to help you make your
goals a reality the book is called the
Great money reset change your work
change your wealth change your life and
Jill joins us right now Jill good
morning good morning what I love about
this book and I like a lot about this
book is that you tell people right here
in the front if you're daunted by the
path ahead I have a message for you you
can do it yeah and you can and the whole
reason that I provided this book as a
guideline was that I was receiving tons
of questions on my podcast on my radio
show from folks during covet and it was
really fascinating because people ask me
Financial questions all the time but the
nature of the questions really changed
amid the pandemic is this really how I
want to live and I would answer these
questions every day seven days a week
and I realize people do need a guideline
a framework and the actual steps
necessary to move forward you don't want
people living with regrets to look back
and say I should have I could have and I
think what's really important is that
most people have some dream and it
doesn't have to be I'm going to hit the
lottery it may be a dream of a slight
change buy a home it could be moved to a
different city it could be shift my
career trajectory and what I really want
to point out to most people is that it's
not an All or Nothing Game here right
there are incremental steps that you can
take but you do have to run the numbers
you know Tony mentioned a powerful word
regret and my favorite chapter seven
start cell or evolve a business and you
kick it off by talking about a woman who
had a great idea I think we all can
identify with this there's some thoughts
that pop into our head and we say oh
this is a money maker yes I should
really do it you might even have a
family member or friend that is
encouraging you but because life becomes
life you get too busy you don't do it
and then what happens you look up
somebody else is making millions
sometimes billions off of this idea why
is it so powerful for people people to
have faith in themselves and just do it
well I think what's powerful is that you
have an idea but we have to execute the
idea so what we need to really do is say
to people that idea is an amazing idea
but you're not going to throw away your
entire life to do that so what should
you do well what we learned a lot in the
pandemic is that a lot of people had
hobbies and they turned them into side
hustles I think that's a great pathway
so hobby to side hustle side hustle lets
you take a small incremental step
forward it helps you test your concept
it allows you to sort of bring some more
numbers to Bear could I actually give up
the the kind of my safety net job right
now and move to this full time and again
you need the framework you have to know
what am I giving up I've got my benefits
I've got my pay I've got all the
coverage that I want in the world and I
have to do this carefully and on the
other side it's also really important if
you have a business Life Changes
conditions change you can shift gears
and it's okay to sell and not maximize
every dollar maybe you need to sell
because it's time to move on what about
this idea of additional education and
people thinking oh the more degrees or
the more training needs a bigger
paycheck how realistic is that what do
you recommend especially knowing how
many millions of Americans that are in
financial debt because they're still
paying off school loans you know I
always wonder education I say well you
know it could be worth it but maybe it's
not and there are three very specific
questions to ask yourself whether you're
going back to school to finish your
degree to get another degree number
question number one what skill am I
trying to actually acquire what is going
to enhance my current trajectory number
two how am I going to pay for it you
mentioned school loans maybe you have to
dip into your own savings that may not
be the best idea maybe you have to ask a
family member sometimes I've heard that
comes with some strings attached so
maybe not the best idea there is the
third question is is there a cheaper
alternative I have found this
fascinating coming out of covid
certificate programs degree programs
companies paying for people these are
the things you should be exploring more
education doesn't necessarily mean more
money it can but I'd love people to ask
these questions Joe let's let's begin at
the beginning though five steps for
people who want to think about a reset
right now so the first thing is you must
take stock of where you are and so I
call this all right it's kitschy The
Fabulous Five okay
all right
what what resources do I have what
assets do I have what what's my income
uh what are the things I'm getting from
my employer in the form of benefits
number one number two liabilities what
do I owe how much money outstanding on
the credit card the auto loan the
student loans what's my housing
situation am I a happy renter is
everyone pushing me to actually buy a
house but I really don't want to buy a
house really important there right what
are the obligations that you have made
to other people which is also very
important these questions along with the
most important one how much am I
spending right now I cannot emphasize
this enough whether you have one dollar
or a million dollars if you don't
understand how much you are spending it
is really hard to reset and take a
different path forward Joe did you write
this book so Katie and I stopped calling
you with money no I did not I I fully
encourage you to do so and I encourage
everyone to ask themselves these
questions again this is a positive
message for me I know sometimes I come
on and say don't do this or do this this
is a message of like you know what you
can do this but you have to be careful
and we have to give you the guidelines
the framework to really make this happen
this helps navigate through the
unpredictability of your finances I'm
telling you I think from all of us here
thank you for all your financial advice
over the years better than a therapist
better than a drink the great money
that's on sale right now and you'll be
back tomorrow to talk about tax season
yay you can make the IRS your friends
she says allegedly